seems good hey i got a king interesting
it for you guys
flu shots we need to know for the baby
here's the thing if you live in la ak
north korea
you're not gonna have a choice they
force you to do it for flu shots yeah if
your kids want to go to school
yeah if you if they want to go to school
they have to get the the vaccinations
and flu shots that's not everywhere
no inoculations basically certain spots
you can get a certain state you can get
like a letter from the doctor or
something like that
oh we did it in arizona certain spots i
don't know about arizona because the big
one is mmr they want you to not have
measles you know
but there's also huge scandals out there
we got bobby kennedy jr coming on uh
tpw tomorrow and he's uh he's not an
anti-vaxxer but he's
he has a lot of issues with the
vaccinations i'm not anti-vaxxing
but i had an issue with my kid right my
like tiger got those and they said it
was from the shots he's
the one percent who had adverse effects
from the shots so it gave him
um like seizures damn oh yeah i remember
that
so i'm anti-vaxxed in that but we could
just be in the minority there
minority dude when i was growing up they
had a bunch of uh you know they tested
um
they tested drugs on animals in our town
at the primate center and they gave out
that's where they made the polio vaccine
in our town oh damn
and so they gave out a bad batch they
made it and they'd already made so much
of it they're like oh well [ __ ] we
can't remake it
but and they're like well some women get
cancer from it and they're like well
that's what it is these [ __ ] gonna
ride with us right now that was it
and they still gave it out to millions
of people like are you gonna get the
corona vaccination
i don't need it i don't need it either
i've already had it
i already had it as well
don't you feel free once you got it i
know you got the antibodies
oh yeah it's like shawshank redemption
for your lungs did you have crazy
symptoms
no no i i had a minor case and i came
back after like a week or two
baby you knew yeah that's stronger than
ever
where did the dick named baby who gave
you that nickname um
me and an ex came up with that actually
um
baby is my mother's old gang name
praise god because she was the youngest
in her family and
yeah they were really high up in there
in lincoln heights that
you know where i'm from yeah yeah you
know you know what it is the main what's
the main gang out there
the main gang uh well my mother's from
clover which is
happy valley uh there's clover and
there's east lake
and it was really just clover back in
the day there's this crazy story about
clover and east lake there was
a kid who was in clover and he was
dating the head dude's daughter
and they were at the park and they ran
into a rival gang and
he used her as a human shield and
found my mother was just so happy to be
driving by and he jumped in my mother's
car and was like i need you i need help
and they're shooting at my mom and like
she's not even in the gang anymore he
just knows her and she's like
trying to get like the attention of cops
she sees a cop somewhere and she's like
yes i'm speeding yes there's [ __ ]
happening
and so like they you know the cops get
them everything is stopped they took her
to court but she didn't say anything you
know that's
that's how i lost stitches am i right
yeah the law street don't say nothing so
she didn't say nothing but
that was the divide this dude and his
friends their east lake and then
the rest of us still clover is the game
called the gang's
called clover west lake east
east lake do they still have gangs over
there um you know what the gang activity
is really it's it's really not happening
as much and
i hear a lot of different things
happening like deals with the fbi and
the cops or cops and
the gangs or whatever yeah local [ __ ]
yep informants
a lot of shitty gangs come up and then
go away fast
man you know like somebody gets an
arrest or somebody gets grounded that's
when you know you have a shitty town
gang somebody got grounded in the gang
activity stuff you can't rob the bank
this week because larry's grounded
yeah we had a kid in our town named cody
and he put all the cocaine and stuff up
in his
air conditioning vent and it [ __ ]
blew into the room
and it got [ __ ] probably pretty fun
though
oh dude i wish i had been there i'd have
been holding my mouth open dude
let it snow let it snow let it snow
oh [ __ ] my first job in la i worked with
cholos uh it was like
on movie sets we were the first people
in and we'd like wrap the walls and just
put
[ __ ] on the ground so they couldn't sue
the production if you damage their house
but i work with cholos and they're like
they taught me they're like you know the
biggest gang in l.a don't you
the lapd
[Music]
is